um thank you so very much for being here
and um for the nice introduction i'm
very much appreciated um i i appreciate
this is getting towards the end of the
conference so i'll try to make it as
more fun as possible interactive um
so um
as we were saying that the title of my
tutorial is previously preserving
machine learning and um i put in the
slides uh the very the covered one the
the link to the to the slides this deck
actually on speaker deck
and
the repository we're gonna use in a
second uh i'm gonna start soon i just
want to tell you what's the plan for
today
i'm gonna start with this presentation
um and i'll tell you what we're going to
talk about what's the plan and blah blah
and then we move on to the hands-on
session and we'll try to do whatever we
can do together
so
the
sorry uh the aim of this tutorial is to
provide you an overview of the emerging
technologies in the in this area which
is known as previously perceiving
machine learning
and in particular we're going to focus
on the python ecosystem there's lots
going on actually around around the the
data science world but we're focusing on
python and the
the approach i'm going to use is the
data scientist approach so we want to
always privilege the
development of the practical aspects of
the thing so whenever i'm going to throw
you
notions which might be no new to you
i don't think i will have the time to go
very much into details very happy talk
about it later but not during the
tutorial otherwise it will be 19 hours
not 90 minutes and um the perspective
will be
the one of the researcher and by that i
do mean i want to give you references
and further readings and stuff you can
read
um and there's also will be some live
coding actually that was the intention
initially and when we're not going to do
live coding but we'll do coding together
for sure
and why i'm doing this um
this is announcement i i wanted to in to
put into the slides uh this is this is
the very first step um of my plans for a
fellowship with the sources and ability
institute in the uk
my plan is actually to give awareness of
this technologies and this is indeed my
very first tutorial so you're the first
audience i have and i very appreciate
your time
today
and which means from my perspective
whatever sort of feedback you might have
for me to improve or you're going to
listen to that would be awesome for me
so thank you very much for that in
advance
um
since i didn't know the audience and let
me just start with a question how many
of you are familiar with pie torch and
deep learning terms
okay so in for for those attending
online it's the majority of the audience
so
is it me doing this sorry
um
and that's my roundy faces getting in
the way um
i will be very quick then
on this warm-up since i know really the
audience i'm i'm going to give you um
just a very quick overview of the main
things we i assume you know already so
some of the terms in the deep learning
things e-box dancers parameters hyper
parameters loss optimizer all these
terms should be
um shouldn't be new to you
if they are please let me know
i will be using this like
bread and butter later uh and in in case
or you want another view of what's going
on with the deep learning thing in the
python ecosystem well um in the in the
pythons then in the zenith python we can
say that there's one and there should be
preferably one way to do it we know that
in deep learning
um
frameworks this is still not the thing
we might say that the machine learning
with cycle learning is essentially that
although secular is not the only tool of
course but it's essentially the standard
or the most popular one
in in deep learning thing there's still
plenty of solutions although i want to
highlight what this is actually a slide
that which is old uh
more than three years as 2018 actually
and and and this thing is actually
improving and we indeed had a very
interesting talk in this conference
about data apis standardization of
n-dimensional arrays and this is
actually exactly one of the important
use case this that standardization might
be useful so going towards having the
same different frameworks but indeed the
same api which makes transition from one
to the other very very cool
and in fact this this twitter from from
a creator of keras and was essentially
showing a showcasing four different
frameworks to do exactly the same thing
and you have to really really be careful
in understanding what the very details
in it to really understand which is
which um essentially so they look very
very similar and
it's going towards that direction of
standardization then
um
[Music]
in the deep learning we have two mains
uh two main family frameworks we have
static graphs dynamic graphs
study graph you have one static graph in
memory and it goes the graph is
important because it will be part of
of the computation we're gonna run and
so you have to keep in mind that
whenever there's a deep learning model
going on there's a graph
and a computational graph which is which
is being sent and processed somewhere
our dynamic graph frameworks are
actually creating this graph for every
epoch as in the animation pi torch it
belongs to this family
and and so the backward propagation
works slightly different and the
static graph is just like you have the
graph you can back propagate it in
dynamic graph you typically record
whatever you're computing and you replay
backward or to to to apply the
optimization in gloss
very quick rundown and main features of
pytorch
numpy like api again very good of having
standardized api for numpy like objects
like tensors you can convert tensors and
nd arrays you can have
either way
you can have cuda support which is
brilliant and whenever we're going to
define a model we're going to have a
class which is extending
an end.module so whenever you have to
define a model in pi torch you need to
extend
and then module you have to implement
the forward method and that's it
essentially and so in the constructor of
the class you have the the definition of
layers which are the tensors
and then to
complete the learning step uh the learn
the training loop you need to define the
optimizer zero the gradient and define
the the loss you want to optimize and
last but not least you also have support
for data set and data loader which is
brilliant fantastic on encapsulation and
the python data model we had
talked about that later yesterday indeed
this is an example of sci-fi using torch
vision and we'll be using something like
that
good
now finally let's talk about privacy
very quickly and and what's the deal
with previously the thing is that ai
models are indeed data hungry and so the
more data you have typically the better
to you or the better the model and the
thing is that there is indeed a push in
in the community for high quality and
curated data set
the problem is when this data contain
data you're not allowed to see so data
that you cannot process because there's
sensitive data and so there might be
different solutions the the first thing
and most obvious thing you can come up
with is okay i have data and i can put
data and models in silas they will be um
locked up
locked up and will be controlled
whatever
uh processing we're gonna do with that
this is actually very impractical to be
fair
and also one of the most popular thing
to do is to apply what is called
anonymization techniques or maybe data
should account for privacy
the thing is that normal anonymization
technique might be
leaking information and this is just one
of the many examples i can give you are
the very popular one on the right hand
side of this light actually left inside
for you
is the robust anonymization of the
netflix private set is very popular
paper actually and the thing is that
this is in a showcasing of an example of
what is called linking attack so you can
uh even if the date set is indeed
anonymized by itself you can link
external data sets to leak external
information and uh that was actually
part of a competition very interesting
and so
advanced more advanced techniques are
actually needed
and we'll try to talk about it later
so um the very first idea i want to
throw here here is
um why don't we all we allow analysis
without moving data from their own silos
at all and this essentially leading to
what is called further into learning so
that the learning is a wonderful problem
actually it's a protocol of
communication and the idea of further
learning is that you have data not
moving at all from the different owners
so you have notes in this network which
owns the data and all you need to do is
essentially sharing the computation you
do on your own data so there's this
accumulating cloud
there
which is um getting all the computation
from the many many clients and and
honestly this this particular worked not
specifically for federated learning
sorry for previously initially but it
was the the model that google was using
to train multiple on different mobiles
that's why you see mobile phones there
and um
so now the question is is that it so is
is further learning the solution to to
rule them all the problem is that um
the answer might be uh will be no of
course otherwise
wouldn't be here talking 90 minutes
about further learning
and the the reason i'm manifold i'm
going to show you two examples we're
going to see later practically
uh one is that models are vulnerable and
one of the most popular examples you
might probably already know is what is
called adversary examples so you you can
perturb the data you can change the
input data to the model in order to
make the model to make mistakes in
predictions and the reason why you want
to do that
may be
many actually depending if you're a
malicious user or you just want to test
your model
it doesn't really
matter to be honest the thing is that
models may be
tricked and this is a very simple case
it's kind of a popular one
as in
you have this input image
and
which is correctly classified as panda
and then you modify with some noise
which is actually carefully selected
and and then you you you come up with
the last image that you cannot perceive
as as changed actually and this is the
trick with the adversarial examples
humans cannot see those being tampered
be changed but the model will of course
notice that and it will classify it as a
gibbon
this is another very interesting one and
this is called model inversion attacks
we're going to work in this specifically
this is taken from a paper and this is
also exposing another quite important
vulnerabilities and models
this is taken from a paper and let me be
clear here this is not the generative
model so the the right
the the picture on the right hand side
is the original
photo
the the figure on the left hand side or
probably the right-hand side sorry the
blurred one has been extracted from a
trained machine learning model which was
not a generative model so it was not a
model trained to generate data it was a
model trying to classify faces
this is a popular one that's back to
2015 but this showcase you the fact that
you can actually
leak sensitive information in think if
uh imagine if this image was actually a
medical data set
something you absolutely don't want to
share with anybody because it's super
sensitive it's the definition of
sensitive data all right
and so we know we
we have to be aware about those things
and there's also another bit um federal
learning
um
requires encryption if you want to
implement it because encryption actually
is everywhere is in the communication on
the channel because if you if you
transmit the data on an insecure channel
actually you don't want to do it
but we want to do an actual step further
and we want to make
the encryption to be smart in the sense
that we want to to get
encrypted data you we don't want to
decrypt the data because those are going
to be sensitive but at the same time we
want to make computation on this data
and this is actually a technique called
the amorphic encryption we're going to
see that in action later on but just
just throwing you
definitions you might be
find familiar or not just just let me
know in case
um
[Music]
automotive encryption is a is an example
of
uh the the pardon me is an example of
asymmetric encryption in which you have
someone holding a private key and the
public key the public is the one used to
do the encryption and the private keys
is used to do the the encryption
and um
this is essentially the the interesting
bit here is that you can
process encrypt the data without
deciphering it
and you can actually do computations
this is the the interesting bit so uh
whenever it comes to machine learning is
always about a matter of multiplication
summations and stuff like that you can
do that on encrypted data and the just
decryption of the of the result in the
in the cipher text is going to be
exactly the same as it was in the plain
text this is the brilliant one
and last but not least in the context of
previous episode machine learning we
cannot mention differential previously
which is nowadays the standard for super
saiyan machine learning method which is
based on a different assumption
not going to go very much in details of
this but
um
the assumption is that instead of doing
any encryption you you start is based on
the idea of
a plausible deniability and
differential previously is a system for
public sharing information about the
data set by describing the pattern of
the groups without
sharing the information about the
individuals which is most of the time
what exactly we're aiming at
and to give you a very practical and
effective example let me just introduce
you the inferential privacy in a way
i've seen
done in this video which was actually
brilliant and and very on topic because
this relates to something we'll be
seeing later on
it's called differential privacy on by
torch
it goes like that so imagine you have
this data set and the state set is
essentially lots of pictures and
you have a very high level of details in
this image
the thing is that you you can use this
image as a whole but most of the time
you're interested in using like uh like
on a single picture most of the time
you're you're interested in in in the
aggregate of the data
set essentially
what you're actually interested at into
using that as a whole as an aggregate
the thing is that um these aggregate
contains sensitive information because
contains the faces of the of the of the
the people in this so this
might be private information
what if we just blur this information
and so
if we do that
will that affect the aggregate
as you can see not much
idea
of using differential privacy most of
the time
we're not even interested in looking at
the individuals we just want the
aggregates for the model training
but if we do if we do get the
individuals we're not allowed because
they're sensitive information so why
don't we do get a sort of noise version
of this data so that we can still
compute the aggregates
without leaking any private information
and i'm i'm telling you there's a as a
as a
story as a fairy tale which makes sense
some
uh
more or less uh but the thing is this
this framework has a mathematical proof
so you have mathematical guarantee that
you're not leaking any information this
is why becoming the standard
and so aggregate can be counter data
competing mean or it could be complex
training and machine learning model and
actually
you can apply differential previously at
different steps
of the pipeline and that the goal
standard now is to applying during the
training you will be seeing that what is
going to be the effect of that
cool so this is it uh before we jump
into that do you have any question
expectation or
things
not entirely clear
good um okay then uh so this is the
repository
i'm gonna open it now i don't know if
there's any oh yes oh very quickly um
what's the agenda three parts we'll try
to do our best um or probably we can
jump through different bits
um first part model vulnerabilities and
attacks are the same examples
the the panda thingy and the model
inversion attack um then we move on to
further
further learning we talk about federated
data for the
machine learning so split and then
and then on
differential previously and deep
learning with um model training uh to
counter attack model inverse modeling
from the model version attack uh first
block just pytorch
second block uh openmind which is a
wonderful community um defining
many tools in this context and the last
bit is about off packers which is
another tool in the python checker
system this is the main three blocks of
technologies we're going to use later on
fantastic um this is the links to again
to the repository and to the slides if
you want to
feel free to catch up with me later on
twitter get a mail whatever you like
good
um
so first things first let's grab the
code on the repository and let me know
if you have any any problem
there should be
i'm going to show you directly
um
that's wrong
one
there you go okay
now i'm going to take this
make it very big
is that big enough
okay so in this repository you might
find you may find the get ready notebook
the get ready notebook is the notebook
that shows you the instructions on how
to set up the environment and to test
that your the environment is working i
don't know if you're using anaconda
python which is the suggested one if
you're not you can use the the there's
the peep requirements equivalent uh to
install all the packages in your virtual
environment it's highly recommended uh
to set up the environment first because
the
especially for the second and third part
the specific package we may need
all right so let me just start with that
i should have probably already going
i was wrong
let me just start
the
jupiter server
are you all familiar with jupiter
notebook by the way
is that a tool you would use to do this
kind of thing brilliant
um
[Music]
that was just the wrong port i think
why 8282
it should be 88
888 right
there you go
good so if you open the get ready
is the font size big enough for you
brilliant
so first bit
set up the environment
and essentially this is the command you
want to run i try to test it on multiple
platforms not entirely sure windows is
going to work
it should be
tried not entirely sure i can't
guarantee it um
and i'd say
then in the rest of this notebook
you should
execute the following cells
and
there are a couple of things to
a couple of cells to run
to test your environment
so that if you're using conda there are
two main commands you want to run
condyle create first and then can't
activate ppml which is going to be the
environment called
as reported in the file the file looks
like that in case you're wondering
that's the one
a few dependencies kind of standard one
i think the the most important one to
report here are packers of course as i
mentioned uh pytorch
pytorch is going to be this version
specifically because it's a dependency
of sift we're using are we using a
version 05 which is currently actually
not very up-to-date
uh there's lots going on for for what i
wanted to present you today um i decided
to go with this version
although i will give you reference to
what to do next with the new version
there's there's a lot going on with this
swift pi shift project
and and changes um are being
applied um
is there anyone who's having troubles in
setting up the environment
i can help you with anything i can help
you with
oh
really yes
that would be interesting to report what
kind of um
yes that one yes this is the the back
that actually i didn't see that coming i
am i'm being honest um
it's a fixed version so that version is
not available in uh
as a pytorch
1.8.1 is not available in condo forge
okay for silicon
i'm sorry about that uh that is
something i will keep in mind for the
future i'm sorry i didn't this time i
don't have an m1 to be fair as you can
see it's an old-fashioned one
and um
and so i haven't experienced this kind
of problem myself uh sorry
um
i tell you i tell you what um
for those of you not willing to this is
something
okay this is something also to keep in
mind for me sorry about that um
in case um
okay i'll tell you what
one thing you can do you can run
everything on collab
that should work
the problem i didn't do it in the first
place is that
if you go but i will very open to
suggestions about that about the
organizations or the thing if you go to
the for example in the very first bit of
modern vulnerabilities in the
modern inversion attack
i prefer not to saturate the notebooks
with python code so i used external
module
sorry about the audio which is weird
and so when you want to run this in
collab you have to import the files
manually
normally if you want to run
notebooks from colab sorry from github
to collab you have to have everything
there otherwise
it's boring and you have to care drag
and drop new files if you if you're fine
doing it
you can you cannot do you cannot do any
setup you can run everything code up
not all the notebooks will have this
issue actually but
you can do that
alternatively
it is it is
you you can yes yes
but uh or you can clone it within collab
so oh yeah that's something i never
tried okay so you don't need to drag and
drop anything
that's brilliant okay okay that's even
better
good
so yeah you you yeah
and does the the git clone set up the
environment i don't think so no so you
have to do it manually okay so uh i'll
tell you what for those of you starting
to work in curry lab i'll tell you what
are the packages needed for different
bits for the first bits you just need pi
torch so don't worry about it if you
have one running pi torch that's fine
and and that's already available in
collab good
let's get started then
if you don't mind
so
i'm going very quickly about the fast
sine gradient method
i want to talk about more extensively
about the model inversion attack which
is more interesting to me
um just going through this um
and to show you the example um
here
of the panda thing um there is an
exercise in the end and you're very
welcome to do it on your own later it's
not really important um i just want to
to tell you how easy it is to implement
these sort of things and and also to
test the
vulnerabilities of models
um
so normally here what we're doing is the
plan with this notebook this is taken
from the adapted from the original
tutorial in the
pytorch
tutorial i didn't invented really
anything
here
i just want to point you the interesting
bit are we using lynette pre-trained on
mnist classical example
and there's something you should be able
also to run on a laptop and nothing is
computational heavy air
[Music]
so this is a very
small net convolutional network and we
download them any state set um
you can go through and run all the cells
it should be working and in the end you
get an accuracy on the test data of 90.
98
then we deliver the attack and the
attack works in a in a very sneaky but
clever manner the idea is that
we want to change so let me go back to
the idea here so the idea we want to
change by a certain amount which is this
epsilon parameter here
uh the original input and the epsilon
controls how much noise you're adding
and the more you add of course the more
is visible to the human human eye
the interesting part of it of this is
that it's actually very easy to
implement because what all we need to do
this
uh the sign of the gradient is
essentially
cleverly selected to fool the
optimization because this is going
essentially taking the sign of the
gradient which is the opposite of what
the optimization do the optimization
normally
goes
in the opposite direction of the
gradient because we're minimizing things
uh here we want to maximize it so we
want to
full let me say for
the
optimizer and so we're
getting the gradient
and pytorch makes things
very easy to do actually
from a an api
point uh point of view so once we have
the prediction on the test data and we
run the attack
what we do is
if the prediction is already correct
uh it is ready it's ready incorrect
it's fine we we skip it otherwise we
take the gradient of the data
and so we run the attack it's a very
simple function
implemented by an epsilon yeah and then
we rerun the the model using the
perturbed data and then we essentially
calculate the accuracy and if you run
this attack with an epsilon of
0.5
what you get in the end is just
94 so you're ready uh ruining the
accuracy
and this is the other solid example five
of underscore example generated
so for example example this was original
s6 has been predicted as a four this was
eight predictors nine and so on so forth
this is just with one epsilon value the
exercise then tells you to try different
epsilons and in the end also seeing how
can you
how can you detect the the fact that
these epsilons have been tampered
originally so the the bigger the
expectation is the bigger is the epsilon
the more the damage on the accuracy but
also the bigger the epsilon the more you
identify the fact that that's a
perturbed and changed data essentially
you can
you can run this
on your own is not
absolutely important if you don't
and this requires some time so if you
don't mind i can just
um close this
on this point and then move on to the
next one unless you have particularly
interest or
curiosity about this
okay any anything from the from the
online audience
yes go ahead is there any way to use
these
adversarial examples in the training
data set yes yes that's a very good
point so the point is is there any way
i'm
should i repeat it for the online
audience okay yes the the question was
about um is there any way to use this
knowledge of others example in a clever
way to to counter-attack
essentially this is what you're asking
isn't it so how can you now that you
know there's vulnerability what can you
do and the plenty of things
the the short answer is yes you can use
the the other side examples the the
thing is um
we're not talking about country measures
we're just
showing you in this case vulnerabilities
but the of course the next step would be
okay i should do something about it yes
very good point
um let me just move on to the model
inversion attack which is way more
interesting and actually even more
intriguing to do and very quick so
um
the reference paper is this one modern
inversion attacks exploits confidence
information and basic countermeasures
i've reimplemented on my own
two of the three models presented in the
paper and the experimental settings
we've been using is exactly the same of
the paper good
so
[Music]
let me just show you what's going on
here so
the the very idea of this
um
the the first thing is we're gonna train
a model to
um recognize faces from the
atnt
faces did set
i wrapped this up into the
pytorch dataset object
and this is called all faces
and you should be able to
download it and
on your machine and get it
i don't get the download because i
already have it on my local machine
but this should start to download and to
get it if you have troubles let me know
um then we set up the the data loader
okay a few notes about the data set data
set contains 400 images of files
corresponding to four different subjects
10 photo each
each photo is that dimension
and a grayscale and is taken at
different
times varying the lights the lighting
the facial expression open close eyes my
links your space and the facial details
the train test partitions i applied in
the training is exactly the same i the
the the authors are using in the paper
we might argue this is not very clever
from a classification standpoint because
this is not very good petitioning
actually but for the sake of the model
inversion is is very clever
the what the the paper is doing is
running peaks for each of the subject
seven faces out of ten those will go
into trading the rest the three
remaining ones are going the test set
all right
of course from this classification point
of view is not very clever but this is
what it is good
um
okay so jim let me just show you
these faces and also have so this is
example faces from the set
let me also show you another note which
is a sort of a question for you
would you please run this and also tell
me that you see exactly the same face
those are randomly selected because
i skipped this but i should focus a
little bit about this this is taken from
the training loader the training loader
has the shuffle
set to true so they are randomly taken
and when i run this you should have
exactly the spaces
do you
brilliant anyone having any guess on why
this is happening
yes it's very up
uh and this is just a
information
i want to give you
always remember to fix the seed when
you're every random things basically all
the time so if you really want to make
things exactly the same regardless of
the machine fix the seed and you'll be
there
so
that particular case
set the seed to
numpy and torch and this is the reason
why you're having despite the shuffling
you have exactly the same faces
displayed
good so uh if we move on um
i already implemented the soft mat so
the models in question are very very
very very let me say again very simple
is soft micro
is called soft max regression and uh as
an extension to logistic regressions
like
it's 2015 paper so it's the terminology
is not super up-to-date to what we have
now and then is multimaster layer
perceptron
um
let me just show you oh the learning
rate is just 0.1
and let me just show you what i mean by
soft max regression
this is the model it's just one linear
layer ending up with a
logarithmic softmax in the end
so
we do train this model
and then we save it
we save the best model here you can run
this as very very quick
you can also run the mlp if you like but
is essentially taking more time so i'm
not going to do it i already saved the
the checkpoints and you don't need to
run this if you want because later you
can download the
the checkpoints already so ultimately
this model is going to have a 94 percent
of accuracy the the multi-layer
perceptron is going to be slightly
better in classifying phases so again
the the the the trade the the
classification uh deal here is to
classify
which is the subject the face is
belonging to
very simple
oh by the way this is the best
validation accuracy we got and so
um this is the model we've been saving
as a checkpoint good you can run this
you're not really required to do that
and the multiple a perceptron is a
linear hidden layer and prediction layer
like that
now that we have
having here is that you're using models
has from an api
you're not having any knowledge about
the model you haven't you're having any
knowledge about the data
and you don't know anything at all about
the model it's a black box
in fact this particular kind of attacks
is called black box testing sorry black
box attacks you don't have
you don't need knowledge about the
internals of the model you just use the
model as a black box
so far so good
just keep the watch under the control
so now the point is
we have the train model we want to
deliver the attack now
so um
in this notebook essentially we're
saying you can skip completely the
training is really not important you can
just
reload in the model on the best on the
best training this is exactly what we're
going to do
so let's try
to run torch
okay
we get the
the date
so this is the size of the data set 280
samples in the training 120 in the test
set
something something up to 400 all makes
sense
and we get the
training data which is the bigger one
good
okay let's deliver the reconstruction
attack and so let me just show you first
what where is the attack
oh he's probably downstairs
right this is the idea of the
reconstruction attack
very quickly the thing is
we want to
pass in
the label we we're aiming for
just the class so the the only piece of
information we need
is that we are dealing with a
classification problem and we're dealing
with some classes identified by numbers
essentially so one two three four
depending on what what what's that it
well that might be
and then we pass some parameters which
controls this this attack alpha beta
gamma and lambda lambda is learning rate
alpha beta and gamma essentially are
some
threshold so alpha is the total number
of iterations we run the attack up to
beta is the maximum number of iterations
without any improvement
is this should be without improvements
uh gamma is the threshold of the cost so
um the
the maximum number of um
loss we can calculate during the attack
and this is the very idea so this is the
general attack
for this particular case we're not using
any auxiliary term so
this is just to emphasize we're not
using any external information so the
auxiliary term in the original paper is
specifically to refer to any
additional information you have on on
the attack you're dealing with all right
we have no
clue whatsoever what's going on
and we just used so this is just to uh
highlight that the initial cost is the
cost generated by the model
so it's the actual prediction of the
training model
and then we keep on going up to alpha
iterations by processing the data we get
from the model and trying to
optimize
uh optimize the um
the
uh generation of of these
uh tensor we're creating by knowing
which is exactly the label
the model is producing
this is the information with works
actually stealing from the model so
we're getting the prediction from the
model as a black box and we're using
that to
as a using the optimization in the other
hand
so let me show you this um
in in in code
so we start with a a tensor of zero this
is the mi face implementation attack
um yes
we start with the with it with a tensor
of zeros so
absolutely nothing
which requires gradient because that's
the trick um
we start with the model which is being
pre-trained and so we get the prediction
from the model actually the the full
tensor of logits
here
then we set up a
loss for the attack and we iterate up to
a number of alpha hydration
we reuse the the model
uh
we zero the gradient of the tensor we're
modifying
and and then what we we get the target
class generated by the um
the cyclic class is the one we're aiming
to so the one we want to steal
and
we calculate the loss between the
prediction and the target class
and then
um
we use
a
sort of a stochastic grade descent
optimization on this tensor so we and
and the last bit is this process
function which is very generic actually
is not doing anything anything at all
this process function is just
normalization between one and zero it's
like dividing by the maximum so is is
the tensor minus the minimum divided by
the maximum minus the minimum it's very
normalization and i'll tell you a second
what's the effect of this normalization
and and we keep on going until some
certain threshold optimization has been
reached using
purely stochastic redesign that's the
another probably another the things i
should say in the original paper they're
using great descent i'm using stochastic
at this end but essentially the same
thing
so this is the attack function
i didn't want to
spoil you anything
sure let me just
for a second let me just clear the
output here sorry i didn't want to
so the the gradient you compute for the
attack you do on the cost function that
and another loss that you define
specifically for the very good point yes
you don't need to know the cost function
of the original model not at all the
model is actually a black box that's a
very good point yes
let me just rephrase this this is a very
good point
so we are creating our own criterion
which is the classification loss
but the model is being used just as a
black box
this loss
which is this one here is between the
target class and the output generated
and so we're trying to
identify which is
which is what is that the model is
actually producing
and if we run the attack on this very
simple model
that's because i haven't run everything
sorry about that let me just redo it
this is the pre-trained model
functions and let me find it so we start
with an empty thing of course
and this is what we end up with we're
just after one iteration
the reason for this is because the model
is overfitted of course and in fact
there's a an extension paper this is in
the slides to be honest uh the reference
to that paper there's a follow-up paper
after this saying that there's a direct
connection with
model inversion attack and overfitting
this particular model is very very
fitted and so you just need one
iteration to steal this kind of
information so just without any
knowledge of the model
we've been able to reconstruct some
information that has been used to train
and so this is still an example but you
have to imagine that things might get
really complicated and and even worse if
you're using sensitive data
i hope this clarifies a little bit the
importance of doing the sort of things
is there any other question so i can
keep going
um by the way another thing i should
mention here is that the quality of the
constructor thing is is not very high
just because i didn't do anything i just
applied normalization that process
function is just to do some sort of
normalization to the data you can in the
paper they're using a technique which is
called um
it's a normalization of images i can't
remember stop my head and moon sorry
but they they the cleaning so to so to
speak because they're normalizing the
results so that they can
look more clear and more evident what's
going on there
very similar to what i showed you in the
slide earlier
and i tell you even another thing if
you're now intrigued by this and this is
just starting let me just
rephrase a little bit this we're just
taking the first 10 class out of 40 and
what we're passing to the model is
the pre-modern the the pre-trained model
and the class we should aim for so i
want class number zero this is what
we're saying
okay
and
um
and as you can see it's always like we
have no clue whatsoever what's going on
but all the time is it's a different
phase so
we we don't know exactly if that phase
will correspond to the actual class
but nonetheless we're stealing sensitive
information within the model
this is called models memorizes and
stuff like that
so if you're intrigued by this
you're very welcome to try the second
bit of the exercise
if you want i can give you uh
five ten minutes if you like
and run this with the pre-trained
multi-layer perceptron
that will take a little bit more time on
your laptop presumably it did on mine
and the code is very similar it's
actually the very same thing
but you will see that the
the quality of the reconstructed images
is even better with this exactly the
same code
and this is because the model is more
complex and so more more parameters more
parameters and so more
space for memorization
that's the takeaway message i'd say
do do you
want to to do this exercise
and try it out
it's really copy and paste
from above
i can do it
with you live if you like
um so mlp
we instantiate mlp we get the weights i
from this link
and i should probably have it already
let me
try the luck here
and all i have to do
yes please thank you
all i have to do is to get the code here
there you go
we load the weights
this time is called mlp
model inversion attack
um this should be mlp
and then we print mlp
that's the model
brilliant now for i or cl in
range 10
mi face
mlp
cl
yes sorry typo here
good it's taking a little bit more time
but as you can see something is
different and sometimes it requires more
iteration so it keeps on going
this is taken 152 iterations
that makes sense actually because the
model is more complex so the
optimization has more parameters to
optimize
but they're not the same
so in some senses it's actually even
better quality
and there's plenty we can do but
nonetheless we're leaking information
the model has memorized
okay was this convincing enough
and again this is not generative model
good so let's see what we can do
um
good
so maybe
in the interest of time since we are
talking already about modeling version
attack let me just use a different order
of topics i had in mind and let's just
keep now to the part number three
so all of this i don't have to repeat
things because you already have it very
fresh and let's move to the differential
previously bit
and
let me just introduce you to alpacas
first things first if you're looking for
a very nice reference i found this book
online which is online and totally open
open source in terms also not just the
source of the the code
attached with the book but also the
source of the book
is really wonderful it's called
programming differential privacy uh
differential preview for programmers so
it's exactly what i was looking for and
it is very very interesting
book
from the book introduction it says the
books assumes a working knowledge of
python as well as basic knowledge of the
pandas and numpy libraries you will also
benefit from some background discrete
mathematics and probability this is all
about
basic undergraduate course in these
topics should be more than sufficient
and these are the references you'll find
in the notebook it's very very highly
recommended and and the striking things
for me was also that the logo of the
book was programmed in python which was
brilliant
and this is the logo of the book and if
you're up to a shameless plug i already
had a
small section of the first chapters from
this book in another tutorial i gave
which is called previously preserving
data science and in particular in the
section of programming privacy you'll
have notebooks
explaining you the difference between
moving from k anonymity to differential
privacy
you'll find it there
and then in this section we're finally
introducing alpacas alpacas is the
pi torch framework for differential
privacy
and
if if you're wondering what a packers is
a packers is a new high-speed library
for training pie torch models with
differential privacy that's more
scalable than existing state-of-the-art
methods
and
in fact it is differential previous is a
mathematically rigorous framework for
quantifying the anonymization of the
sensitive data and it's often used in
analytics with growing interest in
machine learning community
um and let's have a look at how apache
effectively works and to do that i'm
opening the link
um pointed here introducing uh alpacas
which is uh pointing to an article on
the facebook uh this is from a group of
of
from meta so from from the facebook
research
and the reason why i'm here is because
there's this wonderful animation which
is really nice and gives you the idea of
how apaches works and and where
differential previously is used so
essentially this is go this goes like
okay i have a normal training loop
and
you you start from
forward pass and so you get parameters
on the layer one layer two
you calculate the loss and then you back
propagate and normally the way you do it
you uh go layer by layer in the um
backward direction and then you update
the parameters on the optimizer
the way your packers does is that
whenever you have to do this
optimization the the value in the back
propagation are clipped then aggregated
some noise is being added and then those
parameters are then used in the
optimization so
to make it very simple the idea is that
you can add noise during the
optimization to the gradient so that the
the model won't retain any information
because it's going to be and the way of
course the noise will be added
it's according to the differential
previously strategy
okay so long story short the model will
be trained on
perfectly cleverly perturbed data with
noise so that the model won't memorize
presumably and
no previously information will be leaked
and
if you're not believing me which is fair
enough
you might want to see it in action so
let's now train
the very same model soft max regression
using alpacas and i think that the most
remarkable
takeaway message from from this notebook
is how easy is to do it and how
um
how much how less
is impacting the existing code
in fact
um i can import the same things and this
hasn't changed it this is actually copy
and paste from the previous notebook is
just creating the date set i'm not doing
anything fancy here same data set again
blah blah blah again same faces because
the seed is fixed
um
good now
um setting up some
parameters for the for the uh previously
uh sorry differential previously so the
maximum of the gradient norm
uh the epsilon the epsilon makes sense
for the
differential previously is the absolute
differential privacy and the number of
epochs we want to train the the model
uh rule of thumb with differential
privacy it's
recommended to increase a little bit the
number of epochs you want to train your
model because otherwise you're not
presumably getting the same performance
by the way
something i forgot to mention is that
yes we're going to train the model on
this noise mechanism in order to not
leak any information but of course we
don't want the model to
worsen the performance too much so the
deal is we want to change the model to
to save privacy but at the same time we
want the modular works otherwise it
doesn't otherwise it doesn't make any
sense
okay and so rule of thumb just increases
a little bit in the number of efforts
so we
importing the same model
from the same module
creating soft max regression
uh alpacas comes with this validator
which says there's no errors in this
model
if you look at the tutorials this is
showcasing you on resnet and essentially
this is just to tell you that sometimes
some models uh using for example back
propagation uh sorry not back
progression um using um
batch normalization
apologies for that it contains contains
uh layers that are not very compliant
with differential previously so you
cannot apply differentiability on batch
normalization so uh it gives you it
gives you warnings saying you should
change the model actually
also in addition to give you warning it
also comes with utility method that fix
your model for you
automatically it's very brilliant um
so again same learning rate same model
okay and now it comes a packers bit so
from a packers we import previously
engine
and the previously engine is this object
which we instantiate here
and we we create this previous engine by
passing in the model we want to optimize
the optimizer sorry the model we want to
train the optimizer the data loader
and the number of epochs and all the
parameters needed for the differential
privacy
we run this
which of course is not working because i
forgot to run something else
and i apologize for that let me just do
it again
okay
now
i have everything on my hand so i have
this soft max regression which is a new
model with differential privacy i have
the softmax sgd which is the new
optimizer with differential privacy i
have the new loader with differential
privacy the loader is also past the end
because there's a new feature they added
in to had some uh different sampling
from uh which is
also another thing we might want to talk
about extensively uh from previously
preserving perspective but just take it
for granted for now is not really the
point
and now i am importing the very same
function and i promise you it's the very
same function from the same model
module uh the same python module so the
same train function i defined before and
i didn't show you this because it's
really boring it's just like
the normal training loop in which you
have
uh iterate over the different epochs and
then if you
uh you step
the model and the step if it's training
you stop the gradient or not blah blah
it's the same thing it's nothing nothing
particularly interesting here to see
so i'm importing the very same train
function but this time i'm passing to
this function the previously preserving
model the previous per serving of
optimizer and the new loaders with
differential privacy and i run this
and it works
i hadn't
have to change any bit in my code
so if you remember this this is very
highly overfitted so
i i won't expect 90 98 94 whatever that
was accuracy on this model but let's see
where we go
it's taking a little bit more because
there's more epochs
and there's much going on in the back
end of course there's much more
computation going on so of course this
is affecting a little bit the
computation time as well
time is it good
you have a good half an hour to do the
rest of it
fair enough
while this is going till the end do you
have any question curiosity any feedback
please go ahead
i'm kind of surprised if you compare
this just to stochastic gradient descent
where where the individual batch
components are selected stochastically
um so just the fact that you and now
you're adding noise at a different stage
right not not in the selection of
training batches but rather
in the vector of the gradient itself
right yes
so i'm surprised that
this is going to work at all yeah okay i
mean good so first of all why doesn't
stochastic gradient descent itself
introduce some kind of
privacy or maybe maybe i should ask does
it introduce privacy and does the
optimizer that you use
change the privacy of the model that you
learn essentially the the the algorithm
which is in the back end is called
differential previously stochastic
neural descent that's a very good point
and this is the algorithm they designed
to create a backus and
the the strategy of adding noise to the
parameters during the optimization is
what differential previously stochastic
indesign is doing i just i just
showcased you with the animation to give
you the idea of what's going on
the documentation is
is very thorough so you can actually
find more details there
long story short the um the sampling and
the methods of noise
is being added during the optimization
is not just random noise it's just very
selected noise using
different mechanisms the most popular
one is laplace as as in differential
previously but um
there's extensive literature in that
actually
um
in the meantime thank you for the
question uh just a second i come back to
you so we have a 71 percent of accuracy
so of course they're related i don't
know if we can keep on going if we have
any better accuracy but
fair enough at the moment this is what
we have
um doesn't the noise being added during
the back propagation
um become some kind of a private key
then if you have the noise added you can
build it that's a very good point and
that's the reason also why alpacas is is
applying a specific sampling on the data
loader as well
because the the data selection during
the training given
a limited amount of things you can do
especially with shallow models like this
might be
might be leaking some particular
information yes that's very true
so i'm showing you this as a black box
and i promise you there's lots going on
back end and and documentation is
fairly acceptable in my opinion
but of course it's open source so you
can contribute and i'm personally
willing to be to be honest
so now the thing is uh to to
close this block
now that we have the model let me trust
this notebook i know it's not trusting
me um
now that we have the the model trained
with alpacas
we can see
if these ad had any effect on the model
inversion attack
so
calculating
instantiating the
alpacas pre-trained model
re-doing the same thing mi faces and
ronic running the attack
here
and
this is what we get
absolutely nothing at all
so the same attack is not being able to
reconstruct any sensitive information
here and you can keep on going you
always have the same thing
okay
does that convince you a little bit
yes please
um
brilliant question
if you if you look at this
what we're doing
is essentially a form of localization so
indeed
that's for example why batch batch
normalization is is not
required uh that's why you typically
don't do any extra regularization on the
model differential previously is already
a regularizer to the model indeed
yes very good point thank you
i can't remember off top of my head what
what's the role of dropout is um
that's very good point um i can't i
can't
i can't tell you an hour i have to think
about it uh but that's certainly
something i should
remember for next time thank you for the
questions brilliant
any any other feedback question
on this part
just just out of interest does this has
has this work with me showing you the
attack and then the solution
okay i should probably change the
structure later
brilliant okay so now we have sort of
20 minutes
and let me just now show you something
we can do
with the learning which is the last bit
i wanted to present to you
[Music]
so let's introduce failure to learning
very quickly
for the learning is to be fair one of
the most intuitive things in this
scenario and
uh despite the fact that again you have
multiple clients contributing to one big
cloud
cloud of server which is aggregating the
things and then distributing the the the
updated information
um so i i didn't explain clearly how
further the learning works and the very
idea is that the standard representation
of the learning is every single client
has his own data partition
and
their own model
so
every single client
has
capacity to train a model locally on
their own data
and and then every single client
communicates on a secure channel
with this cloud which is gathering all
the different gradients if you're using
gradient based methods
is gathering the multiple gradients from
all the clients
averages it
which means that it's taking into
account all the different clients
and then distributes the updated clients
back sorry the updated gradients back to
the clients
so that in the end every single client
will have the updated model
which has
considered
in implicitly the data from the other
clients
through the aggregation
does that make sense
this is a standard representation of the
learning to be honest there are two
things that nobody tells you initially
and i think they're actually paramount
important
first is that
to make all this to work to to have
everything to work here and to have an
accident to to to make any sense
the features
you're having in this scenario should be
the same for all the clients
so
and and and technically speaking this is
called horizontal for direct learning
the idea of horizontal and vertical of
course because if you have horizontal
there's also vertical further learning
is that imagine the classical
representation of
data machine learning you have samples
and features so you have the matrix of
samples and feature samples on the rows
and features on the columns if you have
horizontal
learning you're essentially taking this
matrix and slicing horizontally so
which means that
the features will are
the same so the the columns in this this
data set are the same just the rows will
be
split through the clients
okay this is horizontal for the learning
vertical is the opposite so you have
the same set of samples
for multiple clients
but each client has different set of
features
and if you're wondering whether any of
this scenario is real
you might think of so the the case of
mobile phones is the case of horizontal
learning because it's the case of we're
having the same features
but
um different
samples in the data set okay
the case of or vertical in on the other
hand is as well realistic imagine that
you're having
some fancy uh health data set
you're allowed to use from one hospital
but another hospital is holding labels
that's the typical example of vertical
learning so you have one client one node
in this network holding
the piece of information relating to the
labels and another client holding the
piece of information about the features
and you can keep on going actually you
can you can have one data set containing
some set of features another data set
containing another set of features but
still the same
subjects
does that make sense this is vertical
further learning we're going to see
example of this
question should i go ahead okay thank
you um
are there any metrics to measure privacy
or how can one major privacy are
achieved
uh could you repeat the question please
what was the the are there any metrics
to measure privacy that's the first
question
are any metrics yeah to measure privacy
and then i don't understand what you
mean by major privacy yeah or how can
one major measure right yeah
sorry privacy achieved
i'm not entirely sure i got what you
mean
i'm puzzled by the use of matrix
metrics
yes
yeah
so i think i think the the question is
um is there any way for you to be able
to measure um the maybe the level of
success or failure achieved what in the
privacy you're looking at oh yes uh
certainly yes um there are tests you can
run on your data to see how much
information you're leaking or whether
yeah this this i skipped this part and
and i appreciate the question it makes
sense actually
and this
if i understood correctly this goes
towards the
data anonymity thing as in how much
information we're releasing um and this
is the very idea of um k anonymity for
example so can anonymity
is built on the idea of how unique is a
record within the data set so how easy
is to spot one and it's just not it's
not just about one single column value
it's also the aggregated columns so for
example if i have in one data set the
the only one sample which is
the the the only
representer for one specific set of
combination of values for three or four
columns that is very identifiable and
this is what knimiti tries to to solve i
think
um in case there's the the section about
previously the science i mentioned
before as a reference there's a question
here
um could you compare differential
privacy with federated learning at the
end again
and then they follow up when should
wish
like one when should
one be used um against another
absolutely which one would you prefer
yes um so th this is a very nice
question and and to be honest i haven't
provided uh answer to that yet because i
i've and i haven't specified what
differential what for the learning can
do i just showed a differential
previously to be fair although uh the
two things can be combined um
and for the federated learning is just a
framework that you can use to
uh in combination with other things
this is differential privacy effective
learning is is another framework in
which you're essentially having
multiple actors in this communication
and involved into into the computation
if you're
having data sets with one single um
silos or database you don't need for the
learning essentially for the learning is
is coming into place when you have
multiple actors so multiple data owners
or multiple
silos of data you want to access this is
and and of course
you can combine further learning we
differential privacy
the two things don't go um separated
but
further learning there's also some uh
sort of uh
cons
so first things first is following
similar to distributed computation too
long to read no
uh client devices have limited network
bandit bandwidth in case of on the phone
examples and and there's also another
deal in for those learning the different
notes
holding the data
since their owner of the data they also
should be allowed to do computation on
this data this is a
major huge requirement for the learning
is imposing which sometimes may not be
attended something like
you're the hospital holding the data i
won't never access those data because
i'm not allowed to i just want to set up
a framework to do computation on this
data so i just want you to
send me the result i'm asking you to
calculate
but at the same time
and that's the deal i don't want you to
steal my calculations because i'm i'm
it might be my
um
ownership
ip yes thank you that was looking for
that's my idea so i have i have my
solution i don't want to
leak my solution to you because i might
be
giving away information private
information as well
not data information but private
information
and so
this is the deal with further learning
with encryption
the encryption and the previously
preserving should be guaranteed on both
ends
this is very roughly and so this is
where we're going yes
is 10 minutes oh you're right thank you
fabulous so uh i think i already
answered this question so
homomorphic encryption i told you
already what's the deal with it and and
and i i probably also give you uh why
you want to do that
so a morphing encryption again is
enables computation on encrypted data
without decrypting the actual data
and moreover any operation made in
ciphertex generates results with then
that's when decrypted corresponds to
result in the plain text which is
amazing um we're going to see an example
of that in a second and
as you may imagine this is going towards
the
um i don't know why it's not trusted
here uh this is going towards the
cryptography
field
i'm not touching it not even close
but there is a huge
[Music]
literature about it
and i will give you in a second
a very nice reference to where you can
go if you're
interested in exploring more about this
everything i've told you today
before closing
so
what we're going to do here we're using
a package in python which is called phe
standing for partially homomorphic
encryption
um
and this is this example has been
actually adapted from what has been
found in the repro uh we're doing
logistic regression using homomorphic
encryption
nothing particularly fancy here we're
using wisconsin breast cancer dataset
we're also taking a context timer to see
how long it takes to do computation
we have its security bit so again alice
and bob
the lack of fantasy here is is
overwhelming
we have alice which has some model which
is the logistic regression model
and then alice is the one holding the
public and the private key so alice is
the one who's in charge of decrypting
things
and bob
will be the one having
to get the public key from alice and
using this public key to encrypt
whatever bob wants to encrypt and send
it back to
alice
uh so in fact
we do get
the weights and the intercept is just
like the parameters of the logistic
expression
and
we use the public key to
encrypt
the um
the parameters of the model
um
[Music]
what i was looking
to is
is this so we generate the pairs of keys
here
and then um
let me just run this so it makes more
sense
very quickly
so this is the data set this is alice
and so alice has the model which fits
the model on some data
makes prediction and encrypt the weights
yes that's the bit
there's bob so we have
data set with some
robust scaling normalization we
initialize alice and so alice generates
the key
for
for bob to to receive
and then we have
alice fitting the model
which takes some time so
no point two seconds very quickly
and so this is just to test the model
performance on on the test data to see
how it works with unencrypted data
and this is it
and then now alice encrypts her trained
model parameters so we have
uh the weights and the intercept so
we're sharing now with bob
the information about the model so bob
takes the public key alice has
harris holds which is the one bob needs
to
use to encrypt
the thing bob is calculating and so
essentially bob what is doing is taking
the parameters from alice updating
according to
his own calculation and giving it back
to alice this is the deal
so set the weights with with the one
encrypted send it by send by alice
and then we calculate the encrypted
value
which takes some times
on the test data by the way so it's
running on the test with encrypted value
so i'm using the encrypted model from
alice i'm not using any any model on my
own
and
and then alice is able to get this
course from bob and decrypt it
and leading to this error in the
in the
prediction
so this is just a very simple example to
showcase um
how uh homomorphic encryption actually
works on
making basic computation like standard
machine learning computation
uh and the composition we're doing here
is logistic regression so
very
basic um if you want to there's a more
extensive example
uh in the end uh showing you how to
implement further learning and morphing
encryption
in this other notebook
before wrapping up i want to show you
um
two things very quickly
the one is the plug about resources i
promised you
and this also connects to openmind which
is this community i reached out to
last year year and a half
which is
um
very active in the the context of
previous episode machine learning and
defining many tools in this context the
most popular one is sift or pi sift
which is now the version 0.6
and
openmind is offering
the private ji series courses which is
totally for free
online
these are the courses which have been
produced so far
and foundations of private computation
is where i adapted part of the materials
in this section which unfortunately
won't have the time to go much into
details
i should better calibrate for the next
time apologies for that but
i'm going to showcase very quickly
before the end and also introducing
introduction sorry to remote data
science is the is the
latest course released in the last year
in which there is a the new version of
pi sift 0.6 which is slightly better
from the version you will be seeing in
this this repository which is using a
completely redesigned
mechanism for privacy using what is
called auto dp auto differential privacy
so it's very focused on differential
privacy and allowing to do computation
using the same framework i'm going to
show you in a second
which is based on uh feathered learning
and encrypted communication
the example
reported here is called duet
and duet is the first prototype they
developed to showcase how you can do
data science on data you're not allowed
to see
uh to do that you have to have two
notebooks we'll be pretending we're
being on two different platforms you can
actually be on two separate machines um
but i'm showcasing you here on this on
my own laptop so i'm doing the client
the service entry so at the same time
the data scientist and data owner
but
let me just close some things
otherwise it's too much
i just want to keep
the reference open for later
to open mind
um
so
pretending i'm a data owner
i have sift
and i'm launching
duet
i'm launching duet so now there's some
server running on the open green network
which is another package uh now
integrated in sift
and this is waiting for someone to join
in i now move to the data scientist
notebook
so the data scientist is the one who
wants to do data
processing on data
they don't have
so i'm open shift
and oh sorry this is data owner i messed
up
so this is the date owner which is the
one that should run first so i am the
date owner waiting for connection
okay
and
this should be already connected because
data scientist now is connected
brilliant so now the scientist and data
owner are connected
the data owner
should
uh
make some data available so in this case
we're having the iris data set
the the the fanciest example i could
think of
we're having
data
split
nothing interesting here
normally data can be any format if their
torch tensor is is way better so they're
ready in the form
they want it to be
um
so we converted it in tensor and then we
we put some description thanks to pi
sift which is extending torch a tensor
adding tags and description and then we
can put the data to the data store
and this is the data store we have a
data set of uh data and target and to
make things very
easy for competition we're just setting
the to accept from the data owner every
possible request
in the in the very top of the notebook
there is reference to the original
notebooks where these things have been
adapted from and you will find extensive
examples about this but again this is
part of the the private ai series course
in particular foundation private
computation
to finalize now i am the data scientist
the data owner has made some data
available for me and is accepting any
request i'm making so it's trusting me
totally and completely so first thing is
let's see if the data set is available
i can
read the data
i can access this data set from the
store an important bit to mention here
is that we have
pointers we're not having data we just
have pointers to some data we don't know
anything about we just know the tags we
know
the description and we know the type
nothing else
um
[Music]
i'm running out of time so i make it
very short essentially what we're doing
is to define a torch model here
which is slightly different from the
standard torch model because it's a side
it's a sift torch model
which essentially needs to
have reference to the remote torch
reference in in in the data owner bit
because this model is being created from
the data scientist and then sent to the
date owner
to do the computation this is the the
deal in fact we do create the model here
it's a local model
but then sorry i forgot to import torch
but then
we send it
to duet so now the model becomes becomes
remote and so if you keep on going and
want to steal any more your time and to
your lunch
you can do
all
the competition considering this pointer
to the remote to the remote model
and you can actually run it and this
computation which is now running is
actually running on the data owner end
so
while this is completing essentially
what i'm doing is
[Music]
getting some data so i'm passing in the
remote model the remote torch the
optimizer which is local and the data
pointer and the target pointer so all
these pointers are actually living in
the data owner end
and the data science scientist is using
it to do some computation which is going
somewhere actually this is performing
some regression
and then this notebook goes like you can
download the model and do the test on
your local data
so this is one example um the other one
uh not showing not having the time to
talk about
unfortunately is another case of and i'm
wrapping up with that is split and then
splitting n is is the
next steps in further learning which is
about i'm not just splitting the data
i'm also splitting the computation of
the models so i may have
some part of the network living in one
client some other part of the network
living in another client and we're
sharing the gradients and finally
aggregating all together and and duet
allows you to do that
um please
feel free to complete this notebook
they're quite
easy to do to go on your own i think
for any kind of issue problem feedback
suggestion feel free to reach out i
would be really appreciative
and thank you very much for for the
extra time and for being here
[Applause]